but let me ask the
the highest challenge the interesting
challenge to this
uh plasticity to this uh livewear system
uh if we could talk about brain computer
interfaces
and neurolink what are your thoughts
about the efforts of
elon musk neurolink bci in general
in this regard which is adding
a machine a computer
the capability of a computer to
communicate with the brain and the brain
to communicate with the computer
at the very basic applications and then
like the futuristic kind of thoughts
yeah first of all it's terrific that
people are jumping into doing that
because it's clearly the
the future the interesting part is our
brains have pretty good methods of
interacting with technology
so maybe it's your fat thumbs on a cell
phone or something but
um or maybe it's watching a youtube
video and getting into your eye that way
but we have pretty rapid ways of
communicating with technology and
getting data
so if you actually crack open the skull
and go
into the inner sanctum of the brain um
you might be able to get a little bit
faster but i'll tell you
i i'm i'm not so sanguine on the
future of that as a business and i'll
tell you why it's because
there are various ways of getting data
in and out and
an open head surgery is a big deal
neurosurgeons don't want to do it
because there's always risk of death and
infection on the table
and also it's not clear how many people
would say
i'm going to volunteer to get something
in my head so that i can text
faster you know 20 faster so i think
it's
you know mother nature surrounds the
brain with this armored
you know bunker of the skull because
it's a very delicate material and
there's an expression in neurosurgery
um uh about
the brain is you know the person is
never the same after you open up their
skull now whether or not that's true or
whatever
who cares but it's a big deal to do in
open head surgery so
what i'm interested in is how can we get
information in and out of the brain
without having to crack the skull open
got it without messing with the
biologicals the part like
directly connecting or messing with the
with the
intricate biological thing that we got
going on it seems to be working
yeah exactly and by the way where neural
link is going which is wonderful
is going to be in patient cases it
really matters for all kinds of
surgeries
that a person needs whether for
parkinson's or epilepsy or whatever
it's a terrific new technology for
essentially sewing electrodes in there
and getting more a higher density of
electrode so that's great
i just don't think as far as the future
of bci goes
i don't suspect that people will go in
and say yeah drill a hole in my head and
do that
well it's interesting because uh i think
there's a similar intuition but
say in the world of autonomous vehicles
that folks
know how hard it is and it seems damn
impossible
the similar intuition about i'm sticking
on the elon musk thing
is just a good easy example uh similar
intuition about colonizing mars
it like if you really think about it it
seems extremely
difficult and uh and almost
i mean just technically difficult to the
to a degree
where you want to ask is it really worth
doing
worth trying and then the same the same
as applied with bci
but the thing about the future
is it's hard to predict uh the the
exciting thing to me
with uh so once it does once if
successful it's able to help patients
it may be able to discover something
uh very surprising about our ability to
directly communicate with the brain
you